Hello Freak bitches.
Now as a person who's governed state and
you look at the,
what happens when someone gets an
office,
when,
when Obama gets an office,
promises all of these things,
gets an office,
changes almost everything.
Um,
what are the hurdles?
I mean,
what are the differences between the
hurdles of someone who governs a state
versus someone who governs the United
States?
And how much more difficult is it to
change things?
It seems like the United States is like
a gigantic ship that takes so much
effort to shift even slightly that these
presidents get out of office eight years
later,
exhausted looking like they've aged 50
years and very little gets done.
Well,
I,
I think there is a silver bullet to the
system and I hope I'm tying into what
you're saying,
but I do think there's a silver bullet
to the system and that would be term
limits.
Um,
I think that for the most part of
politicians,
once they get in office,
the main concern is to stay in off,
right?
And if you had term limits,
I think that people would do the right
thing as opposed to whatever it takes to
get to meet Bruce and for the Senate
Congress Senate anywhere,
right?
Well,
Supreme Court's,
uh,
another topic,
but,
uh,
but certainly elected office
agreed that we have it for the
president.
Why not have it for all elected offices?
I think I'm the best example of term
limits.
I really enjoyed the job.
I had the opportunity to serve for two
terms.
Uh,
so I,
in my estimation,
I press the limits term one,
but not to the point where I wasn't
going to get reelected.
And then when I get reelected I started
off by saying,
you know,
let's examine the drug war in this
country.
I started off by saying that marijuana
should be legalized taking on what I
thought at the time was,
and it still remains so as one of those
really fixable things in our lives,
um,
that would make the world a better
place.
Um,
but because of term limits,
um,
I was emboldened because I,
man,
I was getting out of office and there
was no return.
Right.
Um,
what are your thoughts on all the other
recreational drugs,
not just marijuana,
but the more controversial ones like
maybe cocaine or Psilocybin,
lsd,
things along those lines.
So when I was governor of New Mexico,
I had a um,
uh,
I,
I went to Portland,
Oregon and judges in Portland,
Oregon.
There were judges that wanted to meet
with me in Portland and so I went to
meet with these judges and I didn't know
what the,
what it was going to be about,
but it was six judges,
Portland,
Oregon State district judges.
I'm sure I'm getting the wrong label,
but what they said was,
was,
hey,
governor Johnson,
we just,
we're here to tell you,
we completely agree with everything it
is that you're saying,
but we would like to share with you some
stories here that,
um,
maybe you can pass on to others that
will allow others to better understand
the drug issue.
They said that they're really horrible
drug out there as methamphetamine,
that people that use methamphetamine
really have their behavior altered and
not in a good way.
So it's really the bogeyman drug out
there.
They said I'm methamphetamine.
Is the best example that we can think of
of a prohibition drug?
It exists because it's cheap and it's
easy to make,
and what they said was was that,
hey,
we're not suggesting the following,
but if cocaine were legal,
these people would be using cocaine
instead of methamphetamine without the
negative behavioral consequence,
and that's true,
but if the government were to tell the
truth when it comes to cocaine,
cocaine puts holes in your heart.
People that use cocaine their entire
lives are stereotypically Whitney
Houston that die before they're 50
because they die of a heart attack from
using cocaine.
Now,
will there still be people that will use
cocaine knowing that they might die of a
heart attack?
I think.
I think there'd be less cocaine use if
people actually knew the truth and could
trust government.
When it comes to the truth,
I just maintain that 90 percent of the
drug problem is prohibition related,
not use related,
and that is not to discount the problems
with use and abuse,
but that should be the focus.
When you have 8,000 deaths a year in
this country,
8,000,
which is staggeringly low due to cocaine
and heroin overdose,
and people will immediately say,
well,
yeah,
the number is so low because it's
illegal.
No,
you can argue that if it were legal,
if quality quantity was known,
it's arguable that those desks would
significantly decrease.
Although there will always be people
that will commit suicide.
Always be people that will push the
limits.
Yes,
you're,
you're always gonna have people that
abuse everything.
Everything,
everything,
everything.
I mean,
we're,
we're living in a culture that has
alcohol available at every block all
over the world.
I mean,
everywhere you go,
there's a restaurant or a bar or
somewhere that you can buy enough
alcohol to drink yourself to death.
It's readily available.
Yet when you consider the amount of
people that actually drink alcohol,
the,
uh,
the low number of deaths is pretty
incredible.
And it's because we're aware of the
effects of alcohol and it's pretty.
When you get a bottle of Jack Daniels is
pretty consistent.
Well,
but there are 100,000 deaths a year that
are contributed,
uh,
that,
get contributed to alcohol consumption
and I'm not talking about drinking and
driving or,
or violence committed under the equal
abuse,
alcohol abuse,
statistically,
no one dies from marijuana.
That
what I was going to get to was that when
you look at what's happening in
Colorado,
one of the more interesting things is
the lessening of violent crime and drunk
driving.
Those are two effects that have dropped
pretty drastically,
noticeably statistically because of the
legalization of marijuana that you would
reduce because of the legalization of a
less harmful,
more peaceful drug.
You'd reduce the effects of what's right
now,
a readily available and incredibly
prevalent drug.
I have always maintained that legalizing
marijuana will make for a better planet
on the medicinal side of marijuana.
Um,
marijuana products directly compete with
legal prescription drugs,
pain killers,
antidepressants that statistically kill
100,000 people a year.
No,
no documented death due to marijuana.
On the recreational side,
I've always maintained that legalizing
marijuana will lead to less overall
substance abuse because people are going
to find it as such a safer alternative
than everything else that's out there.
Starting with alcohol.
The campaign to legalize marijuana in
Colorado was a campaign based on
marijuana is safer than alcohol.
And Joe,
as you were pointing out all the
statistics that all the naysayers were
going to go south,
uh,
have gone,
have gone better.
There are less traffic instance.
There's less overall crime in the state
of Colorado.
Colorado is vibrant and does it have to
do with marijuana?
I think that that's an ingredient,
uh,
comprised in why Colorado is so vibrant
right now
questionably unquestionable.
And I think a prime example of how
screwy the system gets when people lobby
against the legalization of things that
don't harm anyone is the fact that hemp
is illegal federally and that we're
trying to make it legal and trying to
make it legal statewide and in various
states and start production of hemp.
But hemp is not psychoactive.
It's crazy.
We,
we,
we can sell hemp products in this
country,
but they,
they come from China.
My bias or my company on it,
we buy it from Canada.
We buy hemp protein from Canada and it
can't grow it in America.
We can import it,
but we can't grow it.
CBD,
CBD oil.
Yes.
Same thing.
Not psychoactive helps pain.
Very effective for people just not
getting people hired.
It's not ruining lives,
not doing anything,
but there's a lot of people that are
concerned that are making money off of
the alternatives.
Especially with hemp.
I mean that was the reason why marijuana
was made illegal in the first place.
That's the reason it was about hemp,
the conspiracy of dupont to promote
nylon as opposed to,
uh,
and,
and of course they,
Randolph hearst with his paper
factories,
they made a,
they made a marijuana illegal.
But because the marijuana plant in the
hemp plant look the same then hence hemp
was also made illegal.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah,
conspiracy.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I mean that's all been proven.
So it's,
we're in a strange time that it's 2016.
It's still illegal.
Again,
slowly starting to become legal and
people starting to,
I believe in Kentucky and a few other
states,
they're allowing farmers to profit off
of this incredibly vibrant plant.
It's easy to grow,
doesn't require pesticides,
has a variety of uses as a textile,
as a commodity for food,
full amino acid profile.
It makes amazing clothes and made this
jacket.
This is made out of hemp.
I mean,
if it's.
If,
if the marijuana plant were discovered
today in the Amazon,
it would be hailed as the greatest
discovery of humankind in 1999.
A good news,
bad news here in 1999,
I was the highest elected official in
the United States to call for the
legalization of marijuana in 2016.
Bad News.
I'm still the highest elected official
in the United States to call for the
legalization of marijuana.
Although Bernie Sanders apparently
rolled out of bed and hit his head and
now he's come to that same epiphany.
Wonderful.
I'm glad,
but in 1990 minutes a roll out of bed
and hit his head on that.
He came to this epiphany at this point
in his life.
He's never said it before,
uh,
no,
not until he's been running for a,
for Senate.
So you think it's like one of those lick
your finger and put it up in the air and
check where the breeze is going.
I'm glad that he's joined the big crowd,
but,
but in 1999,
30 percent of Americans supported
legalizing marijuana in 2016,
60 percent of Americans now are
supporting the legalization of marijuana
and not one politician outside of Bernie
Sanders in office,
um,
is.
And when I say elected official at the
congressional,
senatorial or gubernatorial level,
not one politician in that group outside
of Bernie Sanders,
myself,
have a spouse legalizing marijuana.
I think what a disconnect.
What an incredible disconnect between
what people think and our elected
officials.